who would you say what jordan peterson
is doing in history
who would you have been in the 16 or
whatever the you know the century would
go to who was jordan peterson like if
you were to give a
a a hundred years from now what are
people gonna say who jordan peterson was
they're not gonna say
oh he was a professor
oh he was a clinical psychologist oh he
was an author i don't think they're
gonna say that
what do you think people gonna
correlate you to a hundred years from
now i i really have no idea so let's
just say is it like a philosopher plato
would you say you're more of a
philosopher would you say you're more
like an aristotle
do you see yourself more as that do you
see yourself as
look i'm just somebody that's sharing my
thoughts and my life experiences i think
i think i'm a clinical psychologist okay
so that's kind of how you see yourself
yeah yeah there's a great there's a
lineage of great clinical psychologists
i'm not saying that i'm in that lineage
but i would say that people who are the
most similar to me are people like well
carl rogers might be an example okay i
mean he didn't have the same social
media platform but of course no one did
but
that's how i see myself intellectually
really really as a psychologist as a
clinical psychologist and i think that
the work i'm doing
on my lecture tour is a hybrid of being
a professor and being a clinical
psychologist but is it fair to say
that's who you were but you've evolved
into something way bigger than just
being a clinical psychologist i think
that's what pat's yeah i know you're
gonna be getting out he's comparing you
to an aristotle of some capacity yeah
well i don't know because
my focus is still on the individual even
when i'm lecturing in front of
large audiences and i don't exactly
lecture i explore ideas in front of
audiences which is what rogan does and i
do that even when i'm when it's a
monologue
you know and you think well how can you
be exploring ideas with the audience
when it's a monologue and answer is
well
you're attending to the audience you're
watching them to see if they understand
and if they're nodding and what they're
responding to like there's a dynamism
about it and but it's all focused on the
individual and there's been some
unbelievably influential clinical
psychologists or psychiatrists i mean
freud was unbelievably influential and
so was carl jung and there's a half
dozen sure so so i see that i'm in that
tradition now the fact that
this information now can be disseminated
in audio form and video form makes the
playing field radically different and so
i was also a very early adopter of those
technologies so when i blew up let's say
it happened overnight it's not not
exactly like because most of these
things don't happen exactly takes 20
years to overload
the first doublings are invisible right
yeah but that live outside of the
university yeah well that was that's
that's listen everybody's like who is
this guy yeah he's right he makes sense
so that was a concept of well sure there
was a tipping point there that was when
when there was a free speech rally
outside my office at the university of
toronto it wasn't organized by me but i
was invited to speak as was anyone who
wanted to speak by the way at that event
and then a bunch of radical types tried
to shut it down with white noise and
they were very annoying and some of them
were clearly psychopathic some of the
people i watched them because i have
pretty good eye for that and some of the
men that came out they were bad bad
actors in any case i go got shanghaied
on the way back into my office
by these these
hypothetically trans activists mostly
young people what do you mean shanghai
well they just surrounded me got you
know that's that's all i mean ganged up
on well
kind of they were they were
disrespectful which i wasn't very
thrilled about because i think that
it's not a good
students
if students are being disrespectful to
to to professors
something's wrong that's not
that's not what happens at a university
i i had a
no tolerance for that in my classes if
you were a line you were more than
welcome to leave now and that didn't
mean you couldn't challenge me
intellectually that was absolutely fine
if you had a smart question you were
paying attention
i didn't care what your opinion was but
you know maybe when you're a junior high
teacher or an elementary school teacher
you have to put up with misbehavior
as a professor i put up with there's
like zero
that's no misbehavior we're adults we're
not doing that at all did you set the
tone for that day one in the first class
like this is how i roll yeah i never had
trouble with students in my classes well
a
handful of students would pretty much
always leave
the first lecture i gave particularly my
personality class because a lot of them
didn't who i was in my smaller classes
people already knew who i was so that
never happened but in my personality
class there'd always be six or seven
people in the first lecture would make a
show of leaving and it was because of
the tone i set which was
don't muck about in this class
at all you're here to listen or not you
can leave if you don't want to listen
but this is a serious endeavor any case
these students surrounded me
and uh they filmed it and then they put
it online
and the object was to discredit me but
that didn't work
and but the reason it didn't work in
part and this is why this wasn't only
overnight was i already had a hundred
hours of lectures on youtube and i
basically recorded everything i ever
said to students in any professional
capacity and what i said in my classes
was exactly the same as what i said when
i wasn't in my classes so there was no
there's no show there
and so people came to look to see what
was going on they came to my youtube
channel and it had like 35 000 50 000
subscribers at that point which wasn't
none especially that early on in youtube
development
and they found out that what i was
saying was not only completely unlike
what i was accused of saying but it was
exactly the opposite partly because you
know i was accused of being this radical
right-wing figure and i'd lectured about
the evils of national socialism at
harvard and at the university of toronto
for like 20 years
so the idea that i was somehow radically
right-wing was not only a lie
there's lies where you bend the truth
right that's one kind of lie i think
what i think what those lectures did
is a way for people to not be able to
taint your name by saying i actually
like what this guy has to say so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]